so stay here everybody because guess
what we have liftoff here we go game
started
all right what do we think about these
openings this is obviously oh this could
get there could be a trick here at the
very start
danny do you think that that uh tf oh
there's a trick
oh oh did he prepare this oh oh my gosh
oh this is so dirty carl was just gonna
ask me whether we thought dog dog was
setting the trick and indeed he answers
the question this is a common trap
yeah this happened to me this happened
to me against uh i think papa plot he
did the similar thing where i just
i thought he made a stupid dumb mistake
and then it turns out
no it's it was a debate debated
because yeah i thought the same thing's
literally happening to me against papa
plot and
i blew my mind i swear to god he's still
cheating to this day i'll never give you
german man you
but uh it looks like they just did
something incredibly dumb and so you
just take it
yeah then i think you did it by accident
but this guy definitely did it on
purpose it was definitely well it was
the same it was the same thing it was a
queen h5 checked in so it was like a
queen h5 check with the king on e8 and
something on e5 so it's just the
opposite one okay but it's the exact
same pattern
it's so crazy that he car remembers that
remember well i remember that because
somebody was winning that game and they
magically started losing all their
pieces
what let's talk about this game what do
you feel about this stuff
i think i think dog is going to win the
bishop and tia flade is going through
the same feelings right now imagine
imagine you think you're winning a free
pawn
and imagine no you're losing a piece so
i don't know i mean we'll see if uh this
is not an over game though just because
the piece is
gone there's there's still going to be a
lot of a lot of chances in my experience
there will be a queen blunder at one
point
if if my experience speaks of anything i
anticipate a queen blunder
um well dog we know has been working
hard
you know just like hafu so i guess it's
not that big of a surprise that he would
know an opening trap like this hikaro i
don't know i mean
it's it seems a pretty seems like he was
prepared for this idea
yeah i mean i i kind of wonder what his
training has been like because obviously
with hofu we've seen it we've i mean
we've seen her streaming a lot so we've
seen where she's getting lessons what
she's studying and so forth whereas i
feel with dog
i i know he streams some but i don't
feel like i've seen a lot of chess on a
stream i mean
maybe i'm crazy it's done in the last
couple of days but i feel like in
general we've seen a lot less
so i do wonder like what his preparation
has been especially because i
i assume like he can always hear hafu in
the other room when she's when she's
doing the chess lessons so
um i feel like in some way like he's
probably
trying to do his own things it feels
like the the preparation the openings
have been different than from what
from what hoff was done um but he's
clearly ready for this match i think the
last match when he lost his
extra came as a big surprise i don't
think he was expecting to lose that
match
um so i it looks like he's he feels he
feels more relaxed too
when i just looking at his demeanor he
seems more relaxed more focused than
than i would say um
he was for the first match at the end of
the last game when he lost
hafu came in and i just listened to a
bit of the stream and i feel like she
she immediately was like critiquing him
like the moment he lost his extra she
was like wow you could have done like
mama mama tiger's watching gotta watch
yeah he's watching in the background
let's watch let's watch david ourselves
right now do our first listen in and see
what dog dog is
talking about i'll be okay
not talking about oh man i need to play
chess
okay so what's undefended on mine my
queen is undefended but i can run
that is defended once so what's he doing
here he's attacking this
he brought out his bishop or he brought
out his bishop to attack what
nothing he just brought it out okay so
no threat
so i can push this pawn now and get
control of the center i think i like
that or i can pin it
he's probably gonna castle next turn i
think i like pushing this pawn up
it instincts both are fine actually
i like getting the center pushing my
pawn up
it's fun it's fun
pretty good so far pretty good
everything's defended by one
i need to get my bishops out and i need
to start trading like i need a castle
soon
i don't know where this bishop goes yep
so he castled so pinning is now bad
let's just push this here
and then we'll castle after
it's fine
that actually sets up checkmate right
here
it's undefended but setting up checkmate
is pretty good
it played not like this i like this
i don't like that it's undefended it's
kind of spooky
we'll see if uh if tia blade spots the
segment but lud you said you feel like
people are taking it more serious and
then ricardo talked about
dog dogs prep i mean dog dog i can tell
you was one of the first players who
wanted a second anonymous account
who contacted us so he was taking it
serious from the beginning for sure that
that is sweaty i like that i respect
that because oh
this is bad is this this question yeah
this could be this could be quick
this is going to be h7 now and then he
has to move over it's like
force right you can only go to and if
and if white sees bishop g5 to follow
that lud instead of giving the impulsive
check
bishop g5 could be lights out almost
right away
so walk through the line why is it bad
if you
the reason is if you go here first with
a tempo on the queen you also
invite a piece to this square and if a
piece fills that square to block it or
or the queen even moves to safety this
is now checkmate
instead of just a check that chases the
king out um i'm gonna say something
different
i'm gonna say that uh ludwig there's a
reason that you are the uh the biggest
chess streamer out there and that's
because your idea
of actually making the check first is
correct it's bishop g5
is not the best move danny what was oh
because then bishop
because then you get to pin the
obviously you get the king and get the
queen
of course you know thank you because
look
look obviously i don't have these these
little letters in front of my name so
people can
respect but obviously we see some the
game a little different
you know obviously we do obviously we do
there's a grand master an international
master and the biggest
chess streamer of all time on this show
and and i am on the bottom of that totem
pole
anyway okay yeah so queen h8 wins bishop
two five wins i think kekaro's instincts
are right this is gonna be a short
game unfortunately yeah i the reason i
would say it's gonna be a short game as
well is because when you look the pieces
for black there is no development like
the rook and the queen are on the
original square so black doesn't have
any ways to try and threaten to capture
the white pieces
but that's why i feel like there's very
little in the position for um
or uh for for tf blade
yeah it's almost like it's not just bad
it's that there really isn't even a way
for like
for dog to like mess it up right there's
not even a way for white to kind of
not not just start winning pieces
yeah i i agree yeah now i think he's
going to see it too because if the order
makes sense to check the king and the
queen
and then what's going to happen is check
f6 and then queen takes pawn will be
chuck made i think
wow he sees that yeah i i think it's
gonna i think he's gonna play f6 so it's
a logical reply to stop the check
card has become a premonition for
predicting
the moves of pog champs players we have
a check mate and we're not even
wow we're not even 10 minutes in ludwig
this is your fault you were late
no this is hey this is this is good
they're i was late and then they made
the game go quick
i said i thought it says the dog dog it
says hey hurry up man hurry it up you're
gonna make me look mad
this goes to armageddon i'll look like
an idiot but did you see tf blades look
they're kind of like
okay okay i see what's going on here
okay
yeah i mean it felt like he just got
hard outplayed
like he got beat by a tactic in the
opening and then he didn't even see the
checkmate line
at all like any step of it you can see
the first one with the battery
then he just walked into the mate uh
right
so that was uh that was just like a hard
out play on every street
yeah i just pressed play and took us
through the opening of that trap again
i'll do it again because
because yeah i mean this is a he had to
look at this
he had to have looked at this with
somebody though there's no way i think
that he just plays this instantly
without knowing it yeah i think that's a
really cool opening
the whip out that makes it just like
just looks cool it just looks like
you're a good chess player
right it's because it's a good opening
yeah yeah it's like
plays that move order it is games a lot
if they don't fall for yeah yeah i think
it looks especially good if they fall
for the trap i guess because normally if
they don't then it becomes you know like
every other chess game right what i
would say about that game is that it's
very like we have what are called hyper
modern openings where you don't push the
pawns in the center and that was like a
hyper modern kind of opening setup
very unusual and um uh what is this
opening though
who's been who's been coaching dog uh
i don't know it's not me no i don't i
don't know often oh
no we're not gonna see the same kind of
tactic or with some e5
that would be
okay he gets e5 and if he gets d5 he's
happy so
whoever's been coaching him may have
observed that levy let me work with a
lot of people on the london which
um you know i think levy no no i don't
think levy was coaching dog i'm saying
i think levy was maybe coaching tf blade
although maybe i'm wrong about that
she was chiu teaching i don't know
sorry i've lost track of the coaches no
i'm trying to figure out who's who's
coaching dog like tf blade i think has
had help from chihu
but dogs openings are very unusual like
they they
like i would i i'm that's why i'm trying
to figure out who's coaching because the
openings are so
unusual isn't his coach a secret isn't
he the one that has a secret coach
that's like
also a hearthstone player or something
oh is it delay oh it's like zlatan
it was a secret coach and then he said
it's not delayed but we all think it's
delaying that he's just lying
yeah yeah yeah oh okay i'm pretty sure
he's going to seek a yeah yeah
okay it makes sense because i don't
think
he took a lot of lessons with the
coaches that we hooked him up with at
carter like through the
tournament so i do think like david
meaning dog dog everyone actually has
a mainline coach and all right it's
paying off this is going to be a better
game this game though
i think it's going to be a better game
than that last one do you think it's
going to be a win for
tf play do you want to go that far i
don't think it's going to be a 15 move
miniature that's what i think
i think it might be this opening is off
to a very bad start for white i think
over under 20.5 moves i'm going to take
the under
wow especially after this last move
like this last move is very very tricky
this queen b6 this black wants to take
this pawn on b2
yeah i i mean i just i worry about this
opening it looks
this is what i'm trying to figure out
who he's working with because this is
very sharp and very to the point
it's like it's not something that's like
slow in any way i mean like
it's just very very aggressive at the
get-go it really it really is just very
very
yeah very very very sharp and now bishop
b4 and it's game
it's not it wouldn't be fiddler right he
said hearthstone
i don't think it's svidler it could be i
don't know
but dog dog looks very well prepared
that's what it is he looks extremely
well prepared so i
yeah this is like uh this is i don't
know what happened because i feel like
you know in the game versus zextrow he
he looks kind of like
nervous and now he just feels very
confident in everything he's doing
yeah i mean this is already game over
like
i mean obviously queen d2 is met by met
by a knight e4 but even if he doesn't
see 94 it's still super bad for white
well there's also queen a5
oh and queen so basically ludwig the
reason this is losing is because you see
why can't move the knight because
then your king is captured so whichever
piece you put in the way like you put
the queen in the way
black could just move the queen up to
the side of the board and you're just
going to lose this knight or you're
going to lose your queen no matter what
yeah you're it's just yeah you're
developing moves short of a
full deck you need to be able to bring
the knight out on e2 but
b3 you wish you could play something
like this but since you can't it's
pretty much over
this is brutal though this yeah brutal i
mean
oh he did it yeah if black moves the
queen
one of those two squares i think it's
just game over
d5 or a5 well i guess let's get a look
and listen in again we've got we've got
uh dog dog and he's
giving us his ideas we'll see if i jump
there
what do i do i'm just imagining d4 right
now if i go d4 with my knight
where does he go i don't have that much
he can take my pawn and win it with a
tactic i think i just castle and play
normal
all right push this pawn
i gotta look for tactics here i don't
think there are any
he's just connecting his rooks and
trying to play safe all right i need to
play a move soon
that's okay but it doesn't do anything
right tuck there and there
don't check me okay
let's just uh develop the middle
everything's pretty protected right now
except for this bishop so i'm okay with
it
i just need to make sure i don't lose
the bishop to a tactic of some sort
i could even push this pawn up one more
this pawn is only defended by one this
one's defended by
well you can't jump and take it actually
uh whatever
you guys notice he's very defensive like
it always thinking about yeah
yeah i can take it like this actually
take it there he takes it there
stressed
yeah i mean i think i think he's doing
very well there's only one move for
white that's okay and it's a very hard
move to find
yeah i mean i guess
it's not even okay because a394 but
still
that's a what if i push this pawn up
okay so he's preparing to not die here
if i push this pawn
he takes i take
what happens think i just want a castle
in place if i'm just trying to think of
tactics right now
oh i can attack this
but then he can run away then i take
with check
so let's see if i go e4
i attack the pin piece which is huge
right
if i go e4 i attack the pin piece which
is huge
this is undefended though
then what does he do he can take this
pawn i can attack in and i probably win
the game
this isn't undefended you can take there
can he take anywhere else i don't think
so
and i can't get checked let's do it
you can pin me here it's kind of
annoying but i take
i saw that nod from hikaro you gave the
after that move he's
yeah i mean i think what i would say is
that this is the thing and i
i mean i'm sure it's something
psychological i
i think it's something psychological it
applies to sort of like no matter what
the game is but like
you always assume there's something
wrong it's like you're always a suit you
like even if you have the right idea you
you know there's something wrong with it
because
you know you're not that strong at the
game of chess but but i would say the
majority of the time
the thoughts that these players have is
fairly
it is generally on the right path with
the right track
um i remember you you heard this idea i
said on stream before
of a variation of chess where you can
see the bar
that shows you who's winning the game
like that we would they would see what
we see the analysis bar
live while playing yeah it'd be kind of
like you know when you play a game and
you have like the scan bar and you can
see your enemy's health bar
you couldn't see your enemies health bar
then you'd just be hacking away and you
don't know how long it would last
but if you know you're in an advantage
so you can become a little riskier or
whatever
i think it'd make for better it's funny
you say that because it's actually
something we're working on and it'll
have it's own rating system we've talked
about it called help
chess where both players have to agree
you basically get the email bar call
but i do appreciate that um
no it'll have its own rating and i think
if people play it's almost like just
having that bird on your shoulder
makes you play better right and that's
kind of what you're saying it'd
literally be like having a car next to
being like no you're good and then
you're like okay cool cool cool
all right or he does the well i mean you
know you know
you know what i would say ludwig on that
topic like even at the top
levels the difference it would make in
terms of the game of chess if top
players had some idea
of what was going on it would be huge
because there are many times when we
play at the top level and you're very
unsure
but if we knew that the position was
winning we would automatically be able
to like figure it out
why it's winning or what's really good
we should the type of position changes
based on your facial expression we'll
have your face on the e-bell bar yeah
right so you'll have a happy a happy
face at the top
when you're winning and then kind of a
frowny face at the bottom
okay well i want my royalties for that
okay seriously this is this is uh
someone's got to make a note of this a
lot of chess is a good idea
for sure all right i'm making a note of
one of them right it's kind of catching
on like the name i feel like literally
telling our ceo
i'm telling my ceo after the show remind
me to talk about ludwig chess
it's not me that it's even made it up it
feels like it's the people in a way
kind of latched onto this idea uh
what do we think about the defense here
though from tf blade
i think it's tough i think it's very
difficult
because he's going to lose this rook his
king is in check so it's a double attack
you have to move the king and then the
bishop
will take the rook corner you think
taking with the queen of smarters is
just like
um he should have probably taken the
night and give him the queen so he would
get a night in a bishop and return but
i think it's just very hard and it's
also really like this is one thing i
would say that i don't think we've seen
much of
is when someone's done so when someone's
lost a match because they've been
outclassed
it's something where they're just lost
from the get-go like you just know
they're they're not as good as their
opponent
but here i would say that while dog dog
is a much stronger player
i don't think it's like he it's like he
outclasses tf blade by the same
differential as say a match between like
austin and half thor
so i think it's there's also constantly
like he's on his back foot from move one
and i think it's very unusual to see
that
yeah and i think it almost seems like
the uh the difference is larger icaro
because dog dog is so well prepared that
he's like getting on the right foot and
then it gets exponentially better from
there right
the openings are paid off right yeah
yeah
would you call this a zug zong scenario
we'll call
and it's like the previous one where
there's not much of play in the position
like
he's down on material but also he
doesn't have pieces in the game that's
the problem
so it's very hard to see a way you can
come back
what do you think what do you think is
saying that his rating is too high and
that he hadn't played enough games
but i feel like i feel like his ratings
like feels pretty spot-on
maybe a hundred points maybe too high at
most i feel like he's definitely one of
the favorites
dog dog yeah there were people saying
that he hadn't played a lot of games on
that account
i guess because he has a secret account
so that accounts rating is not
based off a large sample size uh but it
does feel like he's playing
like one of the best i've seen in the
tournament uh because
he also like he's he's also the guy
right he's the same guy who said he was
going to play slow and lose on playing
so
that was that dog dog or is that someone
else same guy who said what
remember there was a guy who said he'd
lose by playing too slow was that dog
dog
you heard that um i believe it was him
maybe i'm wrong so there's somebody
yes it was dog yeah when levi was on
levy said that dog would rather lose on
time
yeah um but you have to get that like
winning position but lose on time or
something
rather yeah play the right moves but
yeah but because of that he
always like analyzes the board and even
really rudimentary things he's like
double checking which is like i mean
most people in this tournament aren't
doing
um right maybe four or five are
so i feel like i feel like you know what
i was giving him a lot of crap for it
last time
where he was talking about how he'd lose
on time which is still losing but
it's i think it's making him play way
better
yeah and uh part of that is the
psychology of the player there are there
are players who just
you know really are much more
perfectionist and then they don't have
it
to kick themselves to move as fast as
they should until until they have no
other choice right there
and then there are players that are
maybe just better or more natural
at you know playing quicker and there
are the other extreme sometimes players
that play too fast
right and just you know don't have a
sense of the critical moment it should
slow down right i think
um when i was a player i think i was all
three of those at one point not all of
us manage our time as well as cecaro
does naturally from the outset but
hikaru did you ever struggle with that
like like when you were younger like
playing too fast right and then you
learn look i'm a fast calculator but i
also need to slow down a little bit
right
what was what is that what would you say
no i mean look be confident and play
good moves man don't don't don't get
down to five minutes and and be in time
pressure every game
just like play the good moves quickly
and
then win i don't know what you're
missing here
play fast and good and you'll win yeah
and then that's the advice it's signed
by tsm
which part of this isn't computing so so
ludwig
oh basically like danny and i go back a
long ways and one thing that you'll see
that's there's a generally there tend to
be like two sorts of schools of thought
which is our players who are move really
quickly and players who move really
slowly and um
i was very lucky because growing up i i
my stepfather he was like
2300 feet a master quite strong at chess
but he would lose a lot of games because
he thought too much
and so i saw that and that was my
example and so i'm like well i'm just
not going to
like think that long right i think danny
didn't have that and he didn't have that
kind of
he didn't have that that that really
really awful example
um set first we need bad examples to
play well no i mean no but kidding i i
mean
yukari's totally right and i think that
you know sunil and hickory car you also
had your older brother
right oscar was a very strong player
right a couple years older than you you
learned from
from you know had a good a good chess
upbringing
you know i was stuck in a small town in
arizona i had to walk uphill both ways
where in arizona where in arizona both
way northern arizona pace in arizona
yeah i know what would you play against
the local
sherpa i didn't i didn't oh yeah
imagine i would go spend summers in new
york and stay with guys like ikaru and
others you know
but it was uh i see you know it was a
sob story ludwig
that is a sob story if you were just
born in the right place
you hey you're you're better than a car
right now yeah
that's what i tell myself if i was born
in the right place that's all it is baby
all right well the queen the queen
blunder you predicted eventually
happened
ludwig uh although it's hard to we're
not we're not piling on tf late he's in
a very tough position
and rook d8 wins the queen it's it's
kind of getting worse here
yeah yeah i feel bad for tf blade
because again i
i think like it's when you feel like
you're really out class is one thing but
it's literally he's in the opening like
the first like three to four moves
the pressure has been on it from the
very get-go in both games it's been very
tough i think
especially when you're newer to the game
of chess like it's not one of those
things that you're used to whatsoever
it's just like
immediately at the start like there's
this instant pressure
yeah yeah this uh we've seen a minus 19
come
back but i don't think that these
players will let that happen to them
what's what's the worst
comeback that you've had happen to you
car or perhaps opposite
if you could well thank you thank you
for thank you for reminding me of very
bad memories a lot of it but i
there was one time that i had a position
against uh magnus carlson that i think
was plus 10 for me and i actually made a
very bad blunder when i got low on time
and i found a way to lose the game
so um okay well okay give us your good
story give us your good story
you came back i don't have a good story
because those things never happen often
what you've never you've had too many
come back at one point
no he's just being one of those people
who only remembers the sad you're never
the pog
right that's how you get good ludwig
that's how you get really good is you
only remember the bad and that's like
all you remember and that gives you the
motivation
you don't remember the good why why do
you want to remember every superhero was
bad
happy every day every superhero was born
out of trouble
i think you can do better than being
happy and satisfied better to be
sad and dissatisfied but better or
happy happy and no good
happy hey i've been lowering i've been
lowering my standards for myself and
getting happier every day
so there's there's a poster child for
that okay
i saw you had a youtube thumbnail popped
up on my feed and it was your brain
exploding because you beat someone's
rank and i was like that's a happy guy
i did i i beat sun and sigouria like the
best game i've played in a title tuesday
in a long time
and it was it was awesome i loved it
brain exploded you're a happy
yeah by the way you guys very quickly
there is one trick here there might be a
background checkmate if tf blade
captures this knight and
and um dog takes with the queen there is
a rookie checkmate that's the one last
thing in the position
i'm going to show it watch the email bar
yeah if you were playing a game lud and
that happened to you your opponent makes
a move
and this happens what would you do keep
it pg
keep it pg oh you know i throw on that
song
like the one where the the celebrate
good times come on and i let it play for
literally
two minutes in 20 seconds until i have
one second left
then i make the move okay i post it on
youtube get 500 000 views call it a day
this yeah this is just over he didn't
take the knight that was the last real
hope i think once dog develops a bishop
and all these ideas on the last drink
uh evaporate i think it's just over
yep yep yep
no more back range checkmate no more fun
pretty rough it's a weird game because
you you
i mean at least the way these people
play it is like you feel like you're
losing and you are
losing and you just keep playing and
and i don't even know why i do it but i
do it every time i don't think i've ever
resigned
i just always go through the motions
it's very depressing in a way
you're just going through knowing what's
going to happen to you but it's
happening very slowly
right yeah it's like being beaten over
the head with like a rubber bat
like not a not a metal one but a rubber
one
[Laughter]
yeah i was trying to
try to bring a visual to your analogy it
was visual
it wasn't that but that was admittedly
yeah
oddly specific maybe we'll check into
some government agencies but for now
uh feels like dog dog's just gonna take
it home
yeah i think i there's no way that he i
mean worst case he he draws the game but
with only one bishop for tf blade on the
board there's no chance
yeah this is over although i feel like
it was over before 20 turns
mm-hmm yeah certainly um
over under do you think hafu walks in
celebrates with them
um i bet i'll tell you guys i think so
she does do you think she does
lets him have the moment and i'll throw
five gifted on it
okay okay sure sure all right i'll take
that are you taking that danny are you
gonna sit down yeah
well we'll i'll we'll throw five kisses
if you're watching ludwig always already
has like i don't know 30 000 subs or
whatever
no no it's 23
and right in la is so expensive people
really don't talk about it enough
i'm outside of tsm you know that's
that's true this is true we can admit
this
this is true yes this is true
[Laughter]
oh man like i will say though i am very
happy for dog because i think certainly
that first match he
felt very demoralized because i mean he
certainly thought he was a big favorite
and then to lose the way that he did
where i thought he was actually more or
less just outclassed in that match
um it's really good to see him come back
and just play a very nice
set of games good preparation too like i
i really am curious who he's working
with
because this feels like really high
quality uh preparation
but and it's high quality hikar and it's
also like it seems to be well chosen
it's like he
he knows these london players are going
to play it so he knows that c5 is
exactly the thing that's just going to
destroy it right you play c5 and move on
so
it's it's it's not the opening itself it
would be brilliant against a good
approach from white but it seems to be
like he's doing his homework and it's
paying off
yeah what's interesting is who will get
into winners bracket from this uh from
this group
right because zextro beat dog dog dog
dog just bit btf blade so the tf blade
zextro
game is gonna yeah incredible that's
huge
they're gonna be playing yeah yeah i
mean i i think the real question is
it really becomes interesting if cutie
beats uh beat zextra
because then isn't it everyone on one
win yeah
yeah that's really fun then you have to
do like insane
tie breakers it's just it's not like
more games right it's usually based off
some
honestly if three people are tied with
the same amount of points i
i don't remember what it is for that so
the event event team will have to get
back on that i don't remember
sure might be a little crazy pool
yeah yeah i mean i i think it's anyone's
bad i will say
though if i look at the brackets i think
this is the one that's most likely where
you could have some sort of weird
what happens if there's a forward can
there be a four-way tie
there could be no people who have well i
guess everyone beats someone else i
think
right i guess it could i guess it
doesn't matter if it goes armageddon
it probably does right well actually
every match has the same points but yeah
yeah right but since this is right
and then it's armageddon right
yeah but i do think this will probably
be the one of the murkiest
on on on who's gonna make it out where i
feel like every other pool
you know going in so your matches feel
like they don't matter
but it is pools at the end of the day so
it's like
you're you kind of are destined to end
up in winners or losers in this like
practice
coming down to cutie and zextro next
this is going to be a big match i mean
she uh
she can do it how how's that what's her
confidence level like bud
uh all-time low all-time low
i mean she's been practicing a lot but i
think you know it's
it's uh it's chess which is
a hard game to improve at and it's hard
to be confident in your moves and we saw
even when listening into dog dog
that dog dog wasn't confident in a lot
of the moves he played today
and he's winning like by a huge margin
and even then he's not confident what
he's doing and so i think what if we
what if we eventually had a pog champs
that was ludwig chess help chess like
we've talked about
i think that would increase the level of
play dramatically
i think we'd be looking at 1 600 level
players a minimum
or you can just do it the better way
where you just have hikaru
and then he'll just he can't say any
words but it'll go
more right yeah and then you know
and then you just keep hovering over
pieces no exactly
yeah but that that is how that's how
little kids play chess when like their
first start like they move
with the hand and then they like look oh
wow he found queen b3 that was a very
nice move by dog dog very nice chuck
mate
that was impressive chia blades in good
spirits
yeah yeah i mean i feel like he he knows
he just got super outplayed right like
it wasn't
you know a close game he could have won
oh i'm sorry ludwig
what she just came in oh she came in
though he's off camera i didn't see it
yeah she came in she came out she came
in she just walked in
you did yeah yeah yeah it's not on a
stream yeah no no no i don't see her on
the stream i don't see you on the stream
here's the time does the count is coming
in it's only a few seconds
she came and gave him a big hug she said
something then on her way out they were
there how do we know it's hawfu
what if it's hafu's twin sister or
something we don't know this
someone's gonna clip it i'm sure all
right all right all right well we're
gonna gift him his subs and we're also
gonna be right back as we get set for
the second matchup of the day we
will probably have some interviews
everyone with our with our last two
players so
don't go anywhere more lud more hiccaro
and more from this lowly im
in just a couple minutes
and we are now joined by the two players
of the round we've got dog dog
david and tf blade and uh well dog dog
congratulations you feel like you you
recovered from that first matchup versus
sex row and
and and found your game a little bit
here in the second match up
yeah i'm well
yeah yeah blade how you feeling
dude i had no idea what was going on i
was like wait
i made one mistake and then boom
everything just like fell apart
yeah it felt like dog dog had some
really good opening strategies dog dog
who's your secret coach
give us any information have you how how
much you've been working with him tell
us at least
that uh so my coach's name is ellie
beret he's like uh he's an old
hearthstone player
and he's like 2100 live i think but uh
yeah he's been coaching me like three
hours every day and uh
he said that whenever you bring out your
bishop like that it gets super punished
so he should just yeah and they he
showed me the lines and he told me to
review him
so three hours a day of work is more
than bloodwick has ever put into
anything
that's amazing all right all right all
right danny moving on moving on
do you think uh do you think there's
anything specific that's helped like
with this training that's made you
improve a lot like do you think you've
improved a lot from last game or do you
think you just played better today uh i
think i just played better today
it's like kind of nerve-wracking playing
on on
not on stream but uh in tournaments uh
i think the majority of the games are
kind of just decided by hanking pieces
so
if i can just work on that and like
focus a little bit more on that and then
maybe like
finding a tactic or two and then just
trade down i should be fine but
yeah yeah i felt you know we listened in
and
pretty much you were just looking for if
any of your pieces were hanging
and then if you didn't see any you would
look for a tactic if you didn't see any
you'd play defensive
that was kind of your strategy and you
did find a few tactics tf played you
said that you were completely confused
by those tactics
but like well how did you feel about
this whole game were you just like lost
were you not sure how to attack or what
honestly i've been only playing like one
opening and one opening only just
because i'm like wait
i haven't i don't know i'm like that
type of player that just likes to play
one thing and get
really good at it yeah but yeah so i
have no i never played against this
tactic actually surprisingly
this was like the first time and we're
playing it live together
i was like wait this tactic being when
he pushed his pawn forward and you
thought he just was being dumb
oh no not that one actually i mean not
not this you mean the game the first
game where you were
black uh
no this game within the next three moves
and then after that i got confused like
the
rook opening the second i did that it
was basically game
over okay i've got them both
but which position are we talking about
here i'm sorry
so you see the rook all the way to a1
the pawn on b2 i think i moved it to b3
yes i've never been punished for that
this was like the first step i didn't
know
what happens after that that yeah there
we go yeah
yeah no that just yeah i
i was just gonna ask i was gonna say one
thing like dog dog um
perhaps you haven't worked on chess as
as much as some of the other
other players perhaps but i i thought it
was very impressive the way that
whether it was with your coach and and
specifically predicting what the
openings were going to be or not like
you just really
you were all over tf blade from the
start of the game from like move one
yeah um um i played one thing so it was
it was good
uh yeah shout out to my coach once again
he uh he carried me
but so he did kind of he did kind of say
that you're probably going to get this
d4 bishop before and had you prepared to
play the c5 line
he just said he always brings his bishop
out on like turn two and then he's like
so
all you have to do is like attack these
squares and then he's like just shove
your seep on and then yeah
they show me the lines yeah
well hey it ended up working out and uh
and your guys pool is actually really
interesting because obviously only two
make it to winners two will go to a
consolation
and it's a little bit up in the air
right now because everybody has at most
one win at the moment i believe so
i think we're gonna have a couple
important games i think tf blade you
have to play zextro still is that right
yeah exactly so that game's gonna be
really big for which side you want to go
on
uh are you trying to go to winter's
bracket because i've seen the past some
people
like feel like not saying that dude at
this point i don't know
like there's so much high reading that i
am so i'm like okay with either way
just give it your best hope for the best
i see just play your best chess and let
it fall as it may
yeah basically that makes sense that
makes sense well i it was a good game
for sure from both of you yeah
uh awesome still do three hours of
coaching dog dog
yeah it's uh it's so exhausting but i
could imagine that's like a lot of hours
and it's like so much information it's
fun doing puzzles i love puzzles
yeah they're the best yeah true dog is
that is that something you were doing
before um the the pogchamps invitation
happened like have you been into chess
or was it
like it was it was this tournament and
then i was like
playing like you know like an hour a day
or just casually and then he messages me
and he's like hey do you want coaching i
was like yeah i think he'd be like one
coaching session
but then he's like the biggest try hard
ever and just
yeah so we're doing like three hours a
day and so your coach is like making you
work on your game all the time breathing
down your neck
yeah pretty pretty much but it's a good
thing it's working i think a dedicated
coach is
so much uh more helpful because then you
don't like if you've coached with three
different people they have to find where
you're at every time or what you've
learned
every time would you be my dedicated
coach
please watching no i don't think so
oh right well hey boys
thank you i mean i i felt that the dog's
coach
did a fantastic job of preparation
giving him good openings
uh i can't do that for you danny uh
because you're so set in your
ways with your openings that are worse
than dogs openings so
saying can't teach an old dog new tricks
something like that sure sure all right
i'll tell your coach that i might be
reaching out to him since i got turned
down but uh
anyway um we're gonna we're gonna let
you go
again uh tia blade like like lud said
you got you got a big match coming up
with sex though pretty much no matter
what happens between cutie and sex are
coming up next so
best of luck to you in that and uh thank
you thank you and david youtube best of
luck to you and your next one it's going
to be this group's going to come down to
the wire so good luck guys
thanks yeah we'll play good games ggs
you